God made me the best I am the best
of what I do play piano same or
something like somebody can beat me
doing that
but that's as far as it goes Jerry Lee
Lewis has died he was 87 years old
[Music]
the rock and roll singers publicist
confirmed the news to E.T revealing the
icon died at his home in Memphis
Tennessee a cause of death has not yet
been released but recent reports claimed
Jerry suffered multiple health issues in
his later years
going on
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah baby baby
Joe is best known for a whole lot of
shaking going on his first track
released in 1957. John Lennon said a
whole lot of shaking going on with the
most perfect rock and roll record that's
ever been down
[Music]
and you've definitely heard his other
big hit Great Balls of Fire
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
and I am rock and roll over my head at
the bottom of my toe the media dubbed
Jerry the killer for attracting crowds
with his wild onstage Antics and if I
didn't like rock and roll had to be a
knuckle Boop or something I mean that's
the best music in the world it's happy
music Jerry is survived by his wife
Judith as well as his sister children
and many grandchildren in lieu of
flowers the family asks that donations
be made in Jerry's honor to the
Arthritis Foundation or music cares the
heart's been real good to me
I've been very very successful I've
worked hard at what I do I do something
do my shows I work real hard for my fans
I love recording records and
you know
and working
[Music]